sie sehen nun die weihnachtsansprache
des bundespräsidenten
liebe landsleute zu weihnachten größen
meine frau und ich sie alle sehr
herzlich ob sie diese stunden alleine
verbringen oder in der familie ob in
einer festlich geschmückten wohnung oder
auf nachtschicht ob im zimmer eines
seniorenheims als pfleger oder ärzten
auf station oder als diensthabender auf
der wache wo auch immer sie gerade sind
ihnen allen ein frohes und gesegnetes
fest
wenn wir auf dieses jahr zurückschauen
sehen wir vieles das uns kummer bereitet
vieles auch was uns angst gemacht hat
wir denken an die schreckliche
flutkatastrophe im sommer
wir denken an unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten die aus afghanistan
heimgekehrt sind und auch an die
menschen die dort in not und hunger
zurückgeblieben sind
wir machen uns sorgen über das was wir
aus vielen teilen unserer unruhigen welt
hören gerade auch aus osteuropa
zugleich war da vieles in diesem jahr
was uns hoffnung macht ich denke an die
riesige solidarität mit den flutopfern
an spenden und vor allem ganz viel
tatkräftige hilfe
ich denke an die vielen jungen und nicht
so jungen menschen die sich für umwelt
und klimaschutz einsetzen und ich denke
an sie alle die ihre stimme abgegeben
haben den wichtigen wahlen und an die
art und weise eines demokratischen
übergangs in gegenseitigem respekt
viele menschen schauen jetzt mit neugier
auch mit hoffnung auf eine neue
bundesregierung die sich viel
vorgenommen hat für unser land
vor allem aber denke ich an das
ehrenamtliche engagement in allen
winkeln unserer gesellschaft so vieles
geschieht der tag für tag im stillen so
viele packen ganz selbstverständlich mit
an sie alle knüpfen tag für tag das netz
dass unsere gesellschaft im guten
verbindet und zusammenhält
ja und dann ist da corona
seit bald zwei jahren bestimmt die
pandemie unser leben hier und auf der
ganzen welt
selten haben wir so hautnah erfahren wie
gefährdet unser menschliches leben und
wie unvorhersehbar die zukunft ist der
nächste monat die nächste woche der
nächste tag auch ganz aktuell müssen wir
uns wieder stärker einschränken zum
schutz vor einer neuen virus variante
aber wir haben doch auch erfahren dass
wir nicht machtlos sind wir können uns
selbst und andere schützen ich bin froh
dass die allermeisten die chance erkannt
haben den der impfung liegt wie viel
schweres leid wie viele todesfälle
konnten dadurch bis heute schon
verhindert werden
unser start war selten so gefordert leib
und leben seiner bürger zu schützen er
braucht dazu die kompetenten
wissenschaftler die ärztinnen und
pfleger
verantwortungsvolle ordnungskräfte und
mitarbeiter in den ämtern sie alle tun
ihr bestes und sie alle gewinnen neue
erkenntnisse korrigieren annahmen die
sich als falsch erwiesen haben und
passen maßnahmen an
menschen können irren
sie lernen aber auch
der staat also ist gefordert er muss
handeln aber nicht er allein
der staat kann sich nicht für uns die
schutzmaske aufsetzen er kann sich auch
nicht für uns impfen lassen nein es
kommt auf uns an auf jeden einzelnen ich
möchte aus vollem herzen der großen oft
stillen mehrheit in unserem lande danken
die seit monaten
umsichtig und verantwortungsvoll handelt
weil sie erkannt hat mehr denn je sind
wir aufeinander angewiesen ich auf
andere und andere auf mich
natürlich gibt es dabei auch streit
natürlich gibt es unsicherheiten und
ängste und es ist wichtig sie
auszusprechen
daran wird bei uns niemand gehindert
entscheidend ist wie wir darüber
sprechen in der familie im freundeskreis
in der öffentlichkeit wir spüren nach
zwei jahren macht sich frust breit
gereiztheit entfremdung und leider auch
offene aggression
es stimmt in der demokratie müssen wir
nicht alle einer meinung sein aber
bitte denken wir daran wir sind ein land
wir müssen uns auch nach der pandemie
noch in die augen schauen können und wir
wollen auch nach der pandemie nach
miteinander leben die pandemie wird
nicht eines tages plötzlich vorbei sein
sie wird uns noch lange beschäftigen und
sie verändert uns schon heute bis in
unsere alltägliche sprache hinein da
sind nicht nur neue begriffe
hinzugekommen von incidents bis 2 g +
auch unsere alten kostbaren worte
erhalten ein neues dringliches gewicht
was zum beispiel bedeutet vertrauen
natürlich nicht blindes vertrauen aber
heißt vertrauen nicht womöglich auch
dass ich mich auf kompetenten rat
verlasse selbst wenn meine eigenen
zweifel nicht gänzlich besiegt sind oder
freiheit
ist freiheit der laute protest gegen
jede vorschrift
oder bedeutet freiheit manchmal nicht
auch nicht selbst einzuschränken um die
freiheit anderer zu schützen
was bedeutet verantwortung
sagen wir einfach das muss jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden
oder betrifft meine entscheidung nicht
in wahrheit viele andere mit
freiheit vertrauen verantwortung darüber
was das bedeutet werden wir uns
verständigen müssen auch in zukunft und
auch in anderen großen fragen wie etwa
dem klimaschutz auch da wird es nicht
nur die eine richtige antwort geben die
alle überzeugt sondern immer wieder
werden wir uns neu verständigen müssen
und ich bin sicher wir können uns
verständigen das haben wir doch in
wahrheit schon oft miteinander bewiesen
liebe landsleute
es war an weihnachten vor mehr als 50
jahren als zum ersten mal menschen den
mond umkreiste die älteren erinnern sich
vielleicht noch an die bilder da oben im
all in diesem moment des größten
menschlichen fortschritts gerade da
wurde unsere kleine verwundbare erde
sichtbar wie nie zuvor
von ihr hatte all der fortschritt seinen
anfang genommen und auf ihr leben wir
alle mit unseren sorgen und hoffnungen
mit unserem leid und unglück
damals lasen die drei astronauten von
apollo 8 den anfang der biblischen
schöpfungsgeschichte vor und sie
beschlossen ihre weihnachtliche
botschaft mit den worten gott segne euch
alle auf der guten erde
liebe landsleute
dass es für uns alle die gute erde
bleibe das ist für uns alle eine gute
zukunft gebe das wünschen meine frau und
ich ihnen und uns heute abend frohe
weihnachten
sie sahen die weihnachtsansprache des
bundespräsidenten